good
morning millennials
[Music]
that was just like let's start it let's
do it again ready yeah good morning
millennials welcome to the morning toast
happy oh friday friday
gotta get down on friday how you can't
hit the gmm notes
but you can hit the friday friday gotta
get done nothing
stops on a friday yeah nothing
nothing stops on a friday should we
start over yeah
this episode is chaotic and i literally
not speak english
no i guess we could keep going since you
addressed the fact okay so we're not
gonna start over okay but we can
mentally start over it's just like not
worth the time we're already on a delay
today
like yeah that's so true okay let's
start in
three two good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning shows happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
nailed it nailed it welcome to the
morning toast sorry for a little
kerfuffle it's friday you know we're
just so
scattered we're so scattered you're
mildly hungover
not the worst that we've seen obviously
not the best but you look really well
you seem well how was your party
tell us everything well if you really
want to know how my party was head over
to patreon.com yeah we did wind up
putting together a patreon party vlog
because someone
was like after all this dress talk like
we better get a party vlog and i was
like glad we could do that and there was
even more dress drama you guys like
you when you see it on the vlog you're
not gonna believe it
so claudia vlogs her getting ready
process not like our makeup routine
again but like you know just like
outfits and whatnot
same with me and then we did a little
vlog from the party so
that should be up later today i hope you
guys will enjoy that but give everyone a
little sneak peek how did you have fun
was it everything you wanted to be in
more do you feel like you're ushering in
your birthday weekend 27 is looking
better than ever
yeah you know i'm actually glad i got
the celebration like turn up part
kind of out of the way because now when
i'm hungover like
the thought of drinking makes me want to
die so i'm really looking forward to
having like a really relaxing weekend
nice that's so low-key of you no i'm
not like other girls this is what i've
been trying to tell you
i'm not yeah so i'm just gonna chill you
know
maybe get a massage for my birthday but
i had a really good time last night
honestly i
looked drop dead gorgeous like and there
was so much drama you'll see in the
patreon like
but i literally left my house and my
doormen were like quaking
were they like who was she i didn't see
this woman come in the building yeah who
was this intruder intruder
literally and i looked absolutely
gorgeous and haven't looked gorgeous in
a while
yeah you know i kind of feel the same
way like i tried a new eye shadow
moment because i was watching like kim
tutorial it just came up on igtv before
i got ready and so i was like i'll
give this a stab and it kind of was
really awesome
so i felt like everyone was like feeling
my look everyone left my choker like it
was just i felt pretty cool
yeah and it's nice to like the way you
look
yeah like when you hate yourself as much
as i do it's nice to change your pace
yeah these moments are fickle and
fleeting i know and of course i didn't
get like one good photo of myself like
so annoying i have this blurry
photoshoot of me like in the bathroom
like that's it
um that's how you know the night was
good yeah no it was and it was so good
to see everyone you know people we
haven't seen since before the pandemia
yeah um i had a great time i'm like not
remembering anything i did start to like
black out towards the end of the night
so
my head is killing me i'm so sorry that
you feel that way but i hope that it was
worth it
it was and i just want to make an
apology i meant to do this
if i saw you last night
at paul's casablanca and i shoved you
i just want to apologize it really
wasn't a shove i was the part of the
night when i couldn't stand anymore and
so like on my way out
there was just like a couple of gals who
i did shove out of the way so how many
how many people are we apologizing to
multiple um
i don't know exact number but if you saw
me at paul's casablanca last night
no you didn't okay i think that's
appreciated yeah no because i really
wasn't shoving i just could not stand
and like she was in my way
you were falling you know it was that
was the leaning tower of guangzhi
yeah i understand things happen yeah and
i just i don't want to be known as a
shover
you know i'd rather be known as a girl
who couldn't stand which is the truth
i think i'd rather be known as a shover
no i wouldn't
well we're just so different we're so
different and we're not we're not like
other girls we're not like
each other i was going to say that
that's so what are the odds
there's only so many things we say here
yeah it's like one of five things
truly um well i'm so glad you had so
much fun i'm sorry did you have fun
i did have fun because for me it was so
nice to be amongst friends and family
everyone chatting hang and drink and
looking good
and it was a great story also as you'll
see and you probably already saw like
there was all these videos of the toast
up on all the screens and like the cma
awards and like
i was genuinely enjoying just watching
it i was wishing we could get some
volume
yeah or like captions or something yeah
no because it was just like so fun to
watch
yeah the event space had all these
monitors he's like do you want to put
something on i'm like
yeah the toast i wish i had a music
video and i would make that
play on repeat but i never did one for
toast and i really should have
you should have but you live and learn
you'll do it for the next song you'll do
it for your ballad called rdh
cause i'm rdh
i don't know how it would go no it would
be like so emotional like
like h like like
titanic like yeah like no like never
enough every night in
my dreams i
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i actually saw a comment yesterday
someone's like what is rth they always
say it but they never say what it means
it means remiss devastated and
heartbroken it's just like a condensed
version of how we feel when we don't let
you know
who today's episode is brought to you by
which is a great segue into letting you
know it's brought to you by
patreon.com the morning toast where you
can always get premium content of your
girls behind the scenes footage
podcast episodes videos moments that you
just wouldn't get on the toast and
you just get so much there at
patreon.com morning toast and
there's so much like footage from the
past
three years that we've done like so many
funny vlogs
chili cook off drunk get ready with us
that like if you sign up for the patreon
today you'll be watching all weekend
long
chili cookoff the chili cook-off with
such good times
oh my god hope everyone is doing okay in
this storm
like the footage coming out of the
subway stations in this town
is disgraceful yeah it is so disgraceful
and
like it was so crazy even though like i
didn't even see any rain
like low-key right because you don't
have wind in a bunker but the rest of us
did also there was like a major flood on
homage to john yesterday
and like 14. 14 cars got stuck
like underwater but the nypd like they
put up like a truck barricade and they
got everyone out so
oh my gosh all good on the mage but i
was like damn not the mush
not the bomb take the subway leave the
majean
wait the majean i was actually telling
you i was talking to someone yesterday
about like the flooding and the um
inclement weather in new york and i was
like and did you see them the major
deegan
yeah it's not the major deegan that's
okay i know but it's
truly the maj dijon like i'm not even
saying it's
because that's like the joke like when i
read it i see mahaj dijon
by the way i do too now even though i
knew that it was major deegan and then
like when you told me that story
it forever became the majdashan so if
you ever find yourself in new york
heading up the fdr
hitting the majdijan make sure to take a
picture for us yes oh i love when you
guys send me the mosh
you know what you should do like if you
ever if you have like an upcoming photo
shoot
like for a project or like whatever i
don't know why you would be doing a
photo shoot
you've got to do it on the mushroom yeah
you need to like jersey turnpike on the
monster challenge that would be iconic
iconic okay i'll look into it in her
interstate
wait sorry ignore me okay well do you
want to get into everything that we need
to talk about i mean i
literally have nothing else to do okay
because also i want to talk about siesta
key because i caught up last night and i
have so many thoughts and feelings i
actually was thinking about it all day
yesterday because obviously it was the
episode i heard it was crazy
yeah spoiler julia had stopped kelsey
and like she was banished from the
island
and she doesn't look like she's in next
episode either like i don't know what
they're going to do about her
and i'm just really disappointed in her
because like juliette is my number one
on the show and like she just
the thing about juliet is like when
she's the underdog you just like you
root for her and she like all of a
sudden starts like
making good choices and like being a
great person and then when she's at
on top she doesn't know how to be on top
without letting everything crumble
you want to be on tap so i'm just
and i'm sure she was really disappointed
in herself and i'm sure i'm sure she
doesn't need to hear it from me
but also just the role that alcohol
plays on the show like juliette was so
drunk and like everyone's just talking
about like
juliet's behavior like juliet's anger
issues blah blah blah it's like if julia
wasn't drinking like that she wouldn't
have slapped anyone
so everyone like also needs to calm down
with their drinking
sorry i know that's not fun to say no
it's not
especially to a hungover person it's not
fun i know that's not fun but you didn't
you don't get super drunk and hit people
no that's inappropriate i've never done
that and if you did
reasoning behind that slap oh because
like they were really egging
i'm sorry i don't want to like say well
okay julia
juliet was very drunk she went up to the
bar and started
flirting but like talking very
excitedly towards max kelsey's boyfriend
because
um i think juliet still harbors all this
resentment because kelsey went to sam
julia and kelsey are not friends right
now but julia goes to the bar and it's
like laughing hysterically i don't think
she was like i don't think she's into
max at all i think she just wanted
kelsey to feel one iota of what she
spelled from kelsey then kelsey comes up
and it's like stop talking my boyfriend
you're in love with him
and juliet's like holding two drinks and
kelsey's like throw them throw them
and of course like julia walks right
into the trap throws them
trashy horrible whatever then they start
fighting again
chelsea's like saying all this stuff and
julia by the way this is literally
drag me monique yeah no that's literally
what it felt like but it was just so
this is just not how you act like and so
this island and kicked her off
production oh for real yeah and i also
feel like it must be really hard to be a
reality tv star because the crazier you
act
the better you are at your job you get
rewarded for negative not even rewarded
but it's like if you really wanted to
like work on yourself
stop drinking a little bit like not
getting so involved in drama like
you're bat you're being bad at your job
you're not interested right and a
reality place is
not the place to do that so you can
always justify your bad behavior when
you're a reality show by saying
i'm doing my job for the show and i
think that's a really hard cycle and i
and i think you get to a point where
it's like
you need to prioritize like the things
in your life that are actually important
versus the show yeah and like her
relationship with sam
is important generally like usually very
good and solid they're still together so
they obviously and they've been together
for a while i think that they have a
really great relationship and like
that should be her focus and her brand
not like being as crazy as she
can possibly be for the show like you
know what let it be someone else's turn
there are plenty of girls in there
who are thirsty enough to do what it
takes to become a mainstay on the show
like
you can sit back like not you don't have
to isn't that what chloe troutman did
like
she really did the job next week she
does she's back next week knocking on
amanda story oh my god they just made
such a big drama i think because
juliette wasn't filming they were like
we can't have two of the like
biggest cast mates out coming back
anyways it was just really disappointing
i'm sure like juliet will
come back from it but it was just i
don't know it just really bothered me
that's it i heard it was a crazy episode
like everyone was talking about
yeah and i guess that's the cs key recap
yeah um
i haven't watched love island since the
first episode but i am going to
catch up and we'll recap like sometime
next week
yeah sounds good but i do think now
without further ado
since we like move stuff around it's
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
this episode's just feeling so chaotic
you know i mean it's a crazy day
i literally can't even speak english
it's later in the day like i did the tv
recap first like it's just
it's we are everything's going we are
muscle wire
haywire are you ready for our first
story it's actually kind of exciting
news i think i found it to be what is it
the bachelor in paradise cast has been
revealed i see this
19 franchise alums kicking off season 7.
what i liked so far is that i knew most
of the people from seasons i've watched
because i'm not watching katie's i knew
most of the people as well but also
there will be more katy guys they just
have to be eliminated from the show
okay so here are our contestants all
that matters
is kelsey weir where is han yes
abigail herringer from matt james's
season
brendan from clarenticious season he was
like number three
um deandra kanu from peter webber's
season there's a lot of peter
yeah i think well because they were
supposed to be on last year
so we have like double the amount of
eligible people yet somehow
grocery store joe is back again but they
love that and i think the fans like that
too like someone
not just like a a first-timer like
someone who like clearly wants to be in
a relationship is beloved in the
franchise
i'm actually surprised there's not more
of those there should be
oh kendall might be there too might be
there too i that to me is like too
chaotic
honestly like i know we've all moved on
but to me she'll always be the girl who
taxidermies
oh interesting the world may have moved
on and forgotten
but i never forget because you want to
know why elephants never forget
ivan from clarentia season
oh my god she was chaotic okay
literally looking forward to her energy
same
grocery store joe he's like the only one
who's like
more than two seasons old carl from each
season what's he on
becca kufrin oh that's not that long ago
carl from katie's season don't know him
looking forward to getting to know him
kelsey from peter season obsessed
obsessed
actually she posted this photo on her
instagram and i was like that looks like
a bachelor in paradise photo but she's
also like
in saint thomas yes victoria and kelly
and i'm like how is she
doing both of those things yeah
confusing i'm confused
kenny from clarentia season oh he was
the boy band manager
oh mari from matt james this season i
liked her
i liked her too she was slept on yeah
she was slapped on i agree
marissa from peter season literally
never seen her in my life
oh natasha from peter season so fabulous
can't wait to see her again
she got like no respect from the
franchise at all noah from
tasha season who was like the young one
who was like
noah vs bennett yeah i liked him i
thought he was cute i thought so too i
think he'll do well and i actually think
he probably just got a weird edit
yeah and he's probably like a nice guy
yeah serena from that season
that there were two serenas right yes
serena c sorry serena see was
the worst one the worst serena well
serena p is also there serena p was
lovely should have won
like literally taken the whole season
home with you the other serena was like
literally the bully
who like got away with it i literally
like i'm still i'm still angry about
that
i know same but i just feel like perhaps
that energy
is right for bachelor paradise yeah and
bachelor in paradise really does
give people a whole new
lease on life like we see you totally
differently yeah villains go
to become unvillainized and heroes come
to die
like yeah paradise can really shift
things around
yep tajuan from colton's season oh that
was our first colton's girl right
oh yeah tammy from peter season oh
remember tammy who could forget who
could forget
the queen victoria from that season
looking very different blonde hairy oh
at first did not recognize her i liked
her like
obviously not her behavior but i'm kind
of like looking forward to her presence
i love people who have no self-awareness
like that's the greatest television
victoria from peter season was she
victoria p
victoria p yeah she was like the she got
like exposed like for being a bully like
right before her time
ended she knew some girlfriend before
time was up like so quick i thought she
was gonna be final four and like yeah
one day it just all turned for her
but she's friends with all the girls so
i'm sure she's fine
yeah um so that's the whole cast there's
definitely more girls than guys because
the guys who are coming are probably
from katie's season yeah
um i like paradise i'm definitely still
gonna watch it yeah same
i am like no is this david spade
this is the crew david spade little john
titus
titus does help but i'm really not
looking forward to
like just give me an arielle vandenberg
you know like you need
a in shows that are so chaotic like you
need
a ryan devlin like you need an anchor
and i just think having like has-beens
on is not gonna help
no i don't think so either it'll be
interesting to watch bachelor in
paradise now that we've just watched too
hot to handle we're watching love island
you love are you the one like to see how
it stacks up against these shows
that it's like trying to be yeah i think
it's actually
very well done well there's one fatal
flaw with the show
which is that it rewards the couples
that are the most solid therefore the
most
boring yeah and there's only so many
slots for people who are single and
interesting and trying to make a
connection
and the further you go it literally gets
like one slot left right and then all of
these people who have already left might
have hit it off with these people who
are coming in and there's just not
i think at a certain point if you hit
like six weeks with the same person
six match-up ceremonies or rose
ceremonies you guys should go to a
fantasy suite a honeymoon suite i agree
because you are boring
and then also that would switch things
up because some people probably wouldn't
want to go so they would like
is it like do i really love this person
do i want to stay on tv that's actually
a really good call
they should reformulate it free idea
free free million dollar idea
yeah yeah because it gets boring when
it's like just happy couples
and then we're focused on like one live
love triangle between like dean
christina
we could be focused on like 18 love
triangles yeah that's actually
really very um well thought out thank
you i've been thinking about it for a
long time this issue and i
just came up with the solution i'd love
to see ideas being made
thank you so much okay next story a
little more love news but not really
chelsea handler explains why her
crush on andrew cuomo is over okay i
think
that's the most relatable headline
everyone's crush on andrew cuomo has
been over for a while
but they were actually like talking
during the pandemic
you know what i just want to say i can
actually see
but before he came out as the
disgrace that he is i could actually see
them as a couple
i could i guess i could see it too so
similar energy i think
chelsea's from new jersey like i think
there
could have been something there yeah the
comedian revealed she had a change of
heart and her feelings for the new york
governor
after multiple women came forward to
accuse him of sexual misconduct
she said i found out all the stuff we
found out about him and i thought well i
guess
this isn't a guy that this is a guy that
doesn't like it offered up
so my crush with him is yes o-v-e-r
she had recalled that she offered
herself up to andrew cuomo
she said in the pandemic i was very
turned on by his morning news
conferences
as many of us were handler um claimed
that he subsequently reached out to her
leading to a couple of conversations
between them
and after saying she said he was
metaphorically feeling himself on the
phone she joked that he could have
literally been feeling himself oh my god
um but then she said she was preparing
to film her special evolution on the
east coast at the time of her
correspondence with cuomo
and thought they could meet up for a
drink while she was in town however that
never happened she said
he blew her off oh my god the more i
learned about andrew cuomo the less i
like him
and he said on the view in october that
while he's a big fan of chelsea handler
he only dates quote new york residents
that's like okay that's not like the
whole angle about being governor
of everything about him like that's not
even that weird but like
it really is i think this is very
emblematic of how a lot of people
their journey was with cuomo evolved
over the course of the year
there was a few words where like
everyone was homosexual and now like
what's the opposite of that that's us no
no homosexual
no no no sexual no no
honestly
i'm so excited this mayweal race is
really heating oh he's the governor he's
the governor forever
no no no no no of course not yeah that
was a dumb question
um i just sometimes forget that governor
cuomo is not married
and i don't know like what what book
it's written the unwritten rule like as
a politician you like are supposed to be
married
so every time i remember that he's not
like the story it's just like oh yeah
it's kind of odd even though there's
like literally nothing wrong with it
it's just bizarre
it's especially odd now knowing what we
know that you know
cause he's a creep yeah right right
right so the whole thing just like
doesn't look good
no not at all but you have to remember
then there was like the sandra lee
who could forget it okay cool the sandra
lee
of it all yeah i think about that all
the time yeah
for those who don't know sandra lee from
the food network was married to
people like no they were i think i don't
think they were domestic partnerships
yeah
like partners like you know yeah also i
was just reading this article central is
on this like fitness journey she's like
five pounds away from her goal
i'm so happy for her i'm so happy for
her we love to see a fitness journey
and she's like she said she's like feels
the hardest they are and she said she
feels like
the best she's ever felt that's really
nice
i just love her i just need to get back
to work start making more some cooking
shows semi homemade like now that i
sometimes cook like i have so much
appreciation for semi-homemade
no it's stunning and her whole aesthetic
was just so rich like
governor's wife and it was just like it
was but that was not her aesthetic
i feel like when her show was actually
on she wasn't even dating
i feel like she was okay with her
excuse me live in new york no i think
she just moved out
that is such a slide in the face that's
like a sign of the times oh my god
sandra lee like i just want to live
where she lives
and i want her to make me like cookies
yeah i'm sure they're good but i'm sure
they're just like
the slice and bake you can make yeah
because she's semi-homemade yeah
it's a great concept for a show great
concept i just really i feel like we've
said this before i needed
food networks to return to their old
programming we've said this and
but i feel like discovery plus like you
can get all that old programming
i i have like a thing like i will not
sign up for discovery plus i'm like
annoyed by it
you're only punishing yourself
by not that might be true there's so
much there for you i wouldn't have to do
it if just they played some normal
cooking shows on
the food network and not quite guys
grocery games every [ __ ] day like
yeah it's
all guys groceries games and diners
drive-ins and dives which is good
but i'm just like can we get g i'll take
giada like i'll take
anyone yeah it used to be like emeril
rachel ray at home with bobby flay like
there was all this [ __ ] like
yeah now would you take bobby fly no no
that's where you draw the line what
is our joke about bobby flam i'm just
like having a brain fart always going
toe-to-toe with everyone it's like
nobody asked him and he like
has this complex where he needs to be
the best at everything but it's like why
can't everyone have their own thing
and the show is 100 rigged now i
remember oh yeah and he's just like
like you can't be the best you could be
a really really really good world around
jeff but you're not gonna be the best at
making every cuisine and like right and
every dish and like leave some space for
the rest of us and like why do you have
to go to these people
gatekeeping he is gatekeeping like
cuisines no but why do you go to these
people's hometowns
attack them set them up with a false
premise for a show that they're doing
you're studying their recipe and they
don't even know they're competing
against you like what's an ambulance
it's an ambush it's an ambush
he is gate keeping like the chef
industry and i ate at a bobby fly
steakhouse once and i did not feel safe
yeah so i just feel like it's just all
wrong like there's enough space for all
of us bobby
lay off bobby he knows he's been really
quiet since that episode
yeah i haven't
are you ready for our next story it's a
little hillary baldwin news
hillary baldwin yeah she's got nerve
again with this caption hillary hilario
no
hillary hillary baldwin claims her
culture is fluid
seven months after her heritage
controversy
we'll read it i just i just am annoyed
how much of an advantage she's no
how much she's taking advantage of the
english language okay
your background in addition to the
spanish cannot be fluid
you are from where you're from and
you're not from where you're not from
and hillary is not from spain yeah but
in an instagram post on thursday the
yoga instructor and my
wife of alec baldwin said she recently
reunited with her side of the family for
the first time in almost two years due
to the pandemic
and that they discussed quote how we
grew up our languages
our cultures multi and very valid
when you are multi it can feel hard to
belong you are constantly going back and
forth trying to be more this or more
that
you feel you have to explain why you are
the way you are trying to fit into a
world of labels where there
might not be one that perfectly defines
you you will never quite fit in because
the other parts of you shape and
influence
all your parts what do you remember
how it was a big scandal that came out
when we found out that caroline calloway
had the ghost writer
yeah who was writing all her instagram
captions yes i think that girl is
working for hillary
natalie yeah or someone of latin descent
is working for hillary what the hell is
she talking about i have
no idea but it's really crazy she's
gaslighting the [ __ ] out of that in
everything it's like she's really still
not like
backing down off of this you know she
refuses to admit that she's
literally lying yeah no she just like
they keep just
throwing like so much verbage at us so
that we get so
bored and we're like oh forget it you
know no i just think as a society we
cannot
let up no because hillary baldwin
pretending to be spanish
will forever be the weirdest thing
anyone's ever done
and i really don't want us to get past
it you know because news cycles shift
people move on with their lives but i
think as a society we should make a true
commitment
to none never forget never forget i
agree
and i feel like most people are very
much in that boat because this was a
story that like took
everyone by storm yeah of course no and
like for me
i really couldn't help but wonder in the
words of carrie bradshaw and people
wonder
like was alec baldwin a part of this
farce or up until a year ago did he
think he married a spanish woman
i think it's the latter that's a really
good question
i know i think it's the former
you think he's in on the farce i think
he like knows where she comes from and
like also realized she was
misrepresenting herself but like was
like
go do your thing no i think that like he
was handled
and you so you think when they came out
you think they were like fighting in
their house
no i think that he's like such a
narcissist that like he thinks the media
this is like the media lying on his
family
and he he actually thinks that she's
spanish like i'm dead [ __ ] serious
yeah still oh okay maybe that
either way whatever they believe they
believe it together there's no
yeah and that's why they're successful
like they are a true universe that's
a great marriage there are unified
fronts yeah they really are i agree with
that but i just don't know what it is
they believe so please just make a
commitment to yourself when you do your
morning affirmations remind yourself
hilary baldwin lied about being spanish
and is literally gaslighting us on
instagram
into like rethinking that she's spanish
and it's important that we remember
first of all that she's not spanish
and second of all that she did that like
she acted like a full other culture for
her entire
life in the public sphere and it's
really kind of lame and embarrassing
and she should be so mortified you know
she should
shame on her house she brought shame on
her family yeah
who's not from spain spain by the way i
don't know if i mentioned that no no
oh no no they're not are you ready for
our next story which is a little
follow-up from news this week that i
found to be quite interesting
suez no unfortunately not that
interesting [ __ ]
everything's all cleared up and this was
what are we going to talk about i don't
know i'm going to have to send like
another big ship there and like just
like turn it sideways
no but kanye helped kim with her
upcoming kkw beauty
rebrand this is really interesting they
might be exes but they're still partners
in business
after kim announced earlier this week
that her kkw beauty website would be
shutting down in august for a rebrand
many fans speculated it was because she
plans to drop the w from the company's
name in light of her pending divorce
from kanye
but a source close to the kardashians
and the beauty company told page six
style that that's not the case at all
in fact west helped his estranged wife
with the rebrand
quote fun little fact kanye helped come
up with the new name kim's decision to
read so there is a new name
yes sir but kim's decision to rebrand
has nothing to do with dropping the w
and kkw
since she has not changed her legal name
and still goes by west
it has been in the works for a while and
kindly actually helped kim to come up
with a new brand name
okay so we're getting a confirmed brand
change name
um but i have wondered about the west i
always thought it was really interesting
that she like when you're a public
person
usually don't change your name yeah not
in such a public way
and like put it on all your branding but
i really know her as kkw like we don't
call her
kim kardashian like she's kim kardashian
west yeah and so i think the way that
her brand became kkw so crazy and like
are we gonna go back to that i don't
know i don't know either so now i'm like
maybe it's not kim kardashian beauty
maybe it's just like
maybe the rebrand is to make it so that
like it's more than just
makeup because obviously chess are
fragrances and like she definitely has
too many verticals and she needs to put
them all together yeah
but i don't know what the name is going
to be but it makes me happy to know
they're still partners
in business and yeah i have to imagine
that they're getting along well
i hope so because kim is not like a mean
or spiteful person she's actually very
calm and lovely
um and connie is like very in his own
world so i actually could see them
co-parenting and being on good terms
yeah because they have so many kids
together and so
it probably requires a lot of
communication and
coordination to make sure everyone's
getting time with the kids
yeah and are the kids going to be like
by coastal you know like
idaho you mean they would just be like
yeah i don't know what the right word is
because it's not by coastal but like
la to idaho why do you keep playing in
idaho
i don't know gotta check out idaho are
you ready for our next story which is a
little more kid news
the kids are out of control the kids are
out of control but yesterday was
penelope disick's birthday and i just
feel like it
took up my entire it did like everyone
was talking about peace birthday i felt
like i got to learn so much about p
from everybody's captions like best post
hands down
if you want to read the caption it was
so [ __ ] funny it was so [ __ ] funny
even chloe commented
did she yeah she said this cat these
captions are hilarious it was
so good it was so good i just feel like
one everybody loves pee
i mean of course everybody loves the
kids but like the fact that everyone was
posting for this camper's birthday
um she's like so stunning for a child
like she's striking
i know and i feel like she really like
as much as we know like north's
personality from like nori
i feel like p has her own personality
for sure i mean her mom is courtney so
yeah i just feel like she's like
cool you know yeah yeah and i think it's
so cool that they're like
so many of the cousins have cousins like
similar ages and they're gonna have like
best friends for life
yes and travis barker gifted courtney's
daughter penelope
drums for her birthday oh my god i saw
that picture but i didn't realize that's
from travis oh my
god i'm like literally going to cry this
is so [ __ ] cute
beautiful i had seen it i'm like oh she
plays drums i do not know that it was a
gift from
travis that means they're really good
drums like the best of the best oh for
sure and nike is the best teacher in the
world
oh my god imagine she grows up to be a
drummer and she's like
i just want to let you know like if
travis barker and kourtney kardashian
don't
like get married or just end up together
like i will deadass be so annoyed
annoyed i honestly like heartbroken
because
this just seems like everything this is
perfect this is like
yeah this story that you just selected
that i didn't even know about like
this is what life is all about yeah do
you know what i mean
kids family music
the music okay he gave her the gift of
music
and that is priceless yeah even though
that's the biggest [ __ ] drum set i've
ever seen in my life it probably cost
like a hundred thousand dollars yeah and
it's pink and crazy and so [ __ ] cute
and it has her name on the front it's
such a cute gift
and i just hope she said thank you
because that's like so thoughtful i
could cry
yeah really really sweet and travis and
courtney are going so strong like
stronger than ever every day that's like
a new outing a new look
yeah but do they ever just sit on the
couch they're always doing stuff
i know well i guess there's so many kids
between them they've got to keep the
campers occupied yeah
but like don't they ever just want to
like lay better watch a movie
yeah i'm sure they do i hope so they
probably watch blended
and they get inspired you i first of all
i've never seen that movie
it's so good you love that movie it's so
good because like you think it would
just be like stupid adam sandler movie
whatever but it has so much heart
and it's so so good if you've never seen
blended adam sandler drew barrymore it's
so
it's so good and if you're thinking
about blending a family or you're in the
you need a tutorial or you're in the
middle of blending one they actually
really don't become blended till like
the end which is spoilers
it's probably it's more like almost
blended um on the way to being blended
yeah but it's a really really cute movie
it's just like so much better than you
would think it is i think you actually
just nailed like the adam sandler genre
it's like dumb adam sandler movie
but like that have a lot of heart like
big daddy dumb
dumb movie had so much time but i feel
like as we get further
as we get further into like the future
the movies get dumber and dumber so like
to have a
sort of like contemporary movie that's
not that dumb you mean his most recent
work
has been really bad yeah i agree um but
he's just in it for the money now
yeah yeah and i respect it do we do
blurs halloween
what was that one who be doobler
because the end had a twist and i don't
remember if i thought there was heart or
it was heartless i because i remember
that the twist at the end but i just i
can't remember what i thought
what was the twist spoil it i'm never
gonna watch this movie okay so
the movie takes place in salem halloween
everybody should i watch it no i'm never
gonna
everything is like so spooky and then
like p and doobie doobler is like the
town
loser always has been always will be
what to say i'm going to find jupiter
his name is literally like who blur
who is halloween who
okay it is called
uh who be halloween yeah what is hooby's
name
hooby's name is hooby okay guys i'm
literally not even [ __ ] with you
his name in the movie it's like who be
hoobly
is hooby hold on hold on
look who'll be g you and then tata top
but i need to get
i think it's safe to say it's hooby
dooby okay hold on no i'm getting so
close i'm going to imdb some people are
like
definitely chef who be dubois french
wait it's dubois dubois
yeah d-u-b-o-i-s oh divorce
du bois no but but it's who we do that
actually does sound right okay
who be dubai
a play on words of heather dubrow
perhaps
okay so yeah who be is a loser biggest
loser always has been always will be
growing up they used to pull pranks on
him and he's like obsessed with
halloween
and and then and he's like really
gullible too and like every halloween
they just like get him with the pranks
because like he's
like a halloween file and he just like
is always going with the flow and like
the town like this you know it's like
the bullies from high school are
still living there and he lives with his
mom and he's just like really [ __ ]
pathetic honestly
even like the kids and now he's like
obviously grown adam sandler's what 50.
like the kids in the town like make fun
of him and like throw [ __ ] at him i
think it's like really bad i just want
to say i'm never watching this movie i
didn't know that it was a sad movie no
it's like really [ __ ] tragic
so someone out there is like uh
pressed that they're treating who be
like this as they should be
and so on halloween night in salem
massachusetts extremely spooky like a
couple people
start disappearing and it's like where
are they going and somebody's basically
doing this for justice for hooby justice
for hovie
literally and you're there's all these
like different forces throughout the
movie and you're like could it be this
person could it be that person
is it just magic spooky like we're in
salem things happen is it the ghost of
witch's past it's his mom
at the end of the day it's his mom she
has all of like oh my god
i just guess that's his lifelong
tortures like hung in her backyard
i love that alive they're just like as a
good mother
should and she's like i think ready to
kill them all um
and um she doesn't and i guess she gets
arrested um
and i just don't know how i felt about
the ending
i just want to say remember i felt
strongly but i can't remember my take on
it i just want to say
your reenaction was riveting like i
don't need to see the movie
i just saw it through your eyes and i
knew it was the mom because i'm smart
and honest
because i told you like six months ago
and you may be remembering no you want
to know how i knew
you literally didn't mention any other
characters so you're like you want to
know who it was i'm like
the mom like that's the only other
character you mentioned yeah yeah like
there was no you know principle like
there was
not a crossing guard like there was no
other characters you mentioned so it had
to be the mom
well there actually were no that you
mentioned that i mentioned right of
course
i tried to say evil forces you know
doobler who be dubois
so that's the latest adam sandler movie
i would have never watched it
but zach made me yeah no sometimes like
it's nice to get into the halloween
spirit even though
i don't know why people still make
halloween movies after halloween town
because that's just never going to be
it yeah did you like that movie is that
the one with the bowl
no that's hocus pocus oh right um
halloweentown that's like disney dcom
yeah yeah it's that girl you know that
like she's got that face she from quince
yes yes she was from the disney channel
original movie
quince which is about five babies her
mom
she's like she's like a kid and her mom
had quintuplets right yeah
and it's just like it's torture you know
yeah and of course
her name is marnie in halloweentown but
in quince she finds a way to make this
like medical marvel
all about herself you know yeah no
totally that's so
crazy now i'm on her imdb she has a
really punchable face
yeah i i'm like not so crazy about
halloween movies like sorry
by the way minnie but i like halloween
love but i love a christmas
film of course yeah you can't just like
stand all the way what do you think is
the best christmas film
not hallmark oh like ones that we're
releasing that really
opens up the floodgates it's elf right
uh
probably objectively yes let's look at a
list of christmas movies
the one where vince vaughn plays
fred claus it's like he's
santa's like dumb younger brother oh
that sounds good
i think that's the premise and i think
that's the that's who plays
fred he's also like four christmases is
pretty cute with him and reese
witherspoon i don't think i've seen that
one
oh they're like each have divorced
parents so they have to go to four
different places for christmas
also the holiday is that oh that's good
christmas it's a holiday movie but also
the one with kristin chenoweth where
they want to see the lights from out of
space
you know um with danny devito and
kristen davis
and danny devito is the neighbor and he
has all these
it might be jack the halls and those
twins from 8th and ocean are in it
the ones with the astigmatism you guys
know what i'm talking about i know what
you're talking about
the astigmatism if you don't know those
commercials
with the twins oh my god with the twins
from eighth and ocean
who have an astigmatism that's all you
need to know there's also that
it's uh are you talking about boy twins
or girl twins girl twins yeah blonde
hair yeah yeah
they were models in ethan ocean yes and
i just feel like
i think that's where we'll draw the line
like if you know that reference like
this is the show for you and like if you
don't
8th ocean was the best show and when it
never came back i was truly heartbroken
yes also an amazing christmas movie that
i personally love is the grinch
might be great might be one of my
favorites absolutely perfectly well done
stunning
also the princess switch of course no no
i agree
a christmas prince the one from netflix
like was pretty good but i never it
wasn't good enough because i obviously i
didn't watch
the next one when i regard holiday films
i don't include any originals from
netflix
me neither like it had to have been
released in theaters like when we were
kids too
in my eyes also uh home alone
is that a christmas movie yes because
like they were going away for christmas
it's also
like low-key like an episode of svu like
they were trying to kidnap him
no as a kid like i used to be really
scared and i'm like why is
everyone laughing at these kidnappers
like yeah it was actually serious
it was a serious threat yeah i agree
just friends you love that movie
i love that movie and
i also don't think of it as a holiday
movie i think of it as like a rom-com
yeah that like happens to take place
during the holidays agreed
it's not a christmas movie okay if you
if you insist
so i think the elf is yeah alpha grinch
grinch is so good and it's so family
friendly and so quotable
so quotable loathe entirely
um okay so i do believe right i
who'll be do i believe that
that is our show wrapping up a great
week here at the morning toast you know
we didn't get you a cake
um but we do want to wish you a happy
birthday because that was
on me and and i forgot and and your
birthday's tomorrow so
things happen [ __ ] i always [ __ ] i
know i actually meant to because i would
have loved you know to crush some
cakes some donuts or something not a
friend there's a prank there's a cake
over there
no like i wish so much i wish i didn't
even mention it because you probably
didn't realize no
why do you think i literally came in
today i'm so i'll make it up to you no i
don't want it let me make it up to you i
don't want the cake
let me make it it's probably for the
best i get i get the message you guys
are trying to we're gonna make it stop
eating we're gonna make it up to you
it's fine do you want to sing to
yourself before we go honestly no
wow that's how upset you are no no
that's how much like i want to
go home that's how much you want on the
show yeah no i love you guys i don't
want to end the show
i just really need to get maybe monday
could be the official birthday
celebration of the claudia on the toast
i mean it's fine like i just think it's
important to remember a few things
not that i was ever keeping score i did
get you a gucci bag like just for the
show
because when we use when we used to say
good bad [ __ ] bad gucci bag gucci bag
we haven't done that in a while because
we don't have a clock and we don't see
when it's 11 11. let's get a clock
digital so we can see yeah um i just
got your gucci bag and i got balloons
for you and then
like that following year like i just got
like a lackluster cupcake from you and
then i stopped
like trying because we were just like on
two different playing fields
okay you know what that's really fair
criticism that's okay good that was i
see what you're
referring to i did get a cake last year
you got a cake last year but it's worth
noting jillian got the cake
and when i got you that celebration we
didn't have anyone
working with us so no it's true you i'm
in the deficit
i'm in the wrong yeah but you know what
i'm in the what's the opposite of
deficit
deficit profit
no you have to go to thesaurus deficit
and then click antonyms
i [ __ ] you guys i think you love an
ant thesaurus.com like ever got hacked
and taken down like the world would
cease to exist i mean if thesaurus.com
didn't exist
this would not exist dead [ __ ]
serious i used thesaurus.com
so much oh and by the way i also use
dictionary.com
antonyms okay but also can i see
something really quickly
people who don't use dictionary.com and
use like miriam webster i just want to
say like
you're a psychopath freaks that's crazy
ass
serial killer behavior sorry continue
are you ready for the antonyms your
deficit
abundance adequacy advantage enough
abundance is good
advantage is good sufficiency but that's
not that seems like
zero sufficient sufficient death it's
like enough
i don't know i was looking for a word
that like rhymes with deficit yeah
preface it
preface it add it miriam well what i was
going to say
was that well i might be
in the preface well you might be in the
deficit for birthday cakes like
i am in the preface it
for like never letting you talk so i
guess we could just call it even
put her there very good very good all
right so all's well that ends well here
at the morning to you
actually yes okay and which one do you
want stevie wonder the classic
the classic happy birthday
to you happy birthday
to you unbelievable
happy birthday dear claudia's good happy
birthday
[Laughter]
to you
okay you have made significant progress
i just want to say like
i really think you should take voice
lessons because like
the thing is is like
you want to have a good voice so bad so
bad more than anything and it's like
just not fair that you don't have
and it's like it makes you think because
at the end of the day like people have
good voices are so supremely talented
but it's also just luck it's not talent
no fans like
you didn't earn it and of course you can
trade
but you're either born with it or not
it's
privileged like it is it's no you're 100
right
and when like when we compliment singers
and they're like thank you like
you didn't do anything no thank god
literally
literally i think that's a great way to
end the show happy birthday club we love
you so much you don't look a day
over 22.
yeah people think i'm like 45. oh my god
last night i was talking to someone who
listens to the toast and didn't know how
old i was and like she was saying how
she's so old i was like how old could he
possibly be and then
she was like how old are you when i was
like 28. and she's like oh my god i
thought you were in your 30s i was like
oh because i'm a grandma like
because i give off grandma my she's like
yeah no actually i guess like the way
that
my energy is just older well if that's
the case like i drink like an
eighteen-year-old
no so i guess but people always think
i'm old but weight adds a factor like
people just think you're older when
you're fat
you think yeah i do
but also sometimes like it like you get
liposuction just like hall of the day
bring me with you okay um theo
i love you thank you for being literally
just a heavenly being he's the greatest
gift
remember that
you are literally reading my mind i'm so
freaked out he is
the literal mascot of heavenly bodies
yeah
i would agree with that thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast also
um if you do want to get me a present
i'm registered
at bloomingdale's thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show
where we deliver the first or we deliver
the best of stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also about
lots of podcasts anywhere but guests can
be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio cast
box
all the places so let me listen to
podcast find us morning tell us leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
guys have an amazing weekend
stay safe buy me a present and have a
great day
love you bye
you